[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants nés nounours tu
portes des bijoux ce soir oui patron
c'est un bijou joujou vont jouer au jeu
de l'anneau à je comprends et je vous
laisse le soin d'expliquer les règles du
jeu à tous nos petits amis europe je
descends hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
amusez vous bien
voilà les enfants c'est un jeu très
divertissant
tous les joueurs se cachent les yeux
sans tricher ou sortent de la pièce où
l'on joue sauf un qui pose l'anneau bien
visible sans le cacher il crie alors ça
y est et le premier qui l'a trouvé à
gagner
[Musique]
la place d'un anneau c'est sur un rideau
ils étaient cachés sous un lit non il
est bien visible sur le méfait elle
[Musique]
est bien gérée et à pourquoi gritti fort
bravo majid y est un gros malade louvain
il la met sur son oreille nous pourrions
toujours cherché à nous juliette a on va
cacher un ensemble
il regardait pas vous louez un gros nom
soit tranquille mon petit cornichons
soit 38 au nude hedrich tu regarde d'un
oeil aux étoiles adam tutrice des deux
yeux ah non non c'est pas possible via
julietta on va dans une autre pièce ni
quand ni chat je vais aussi au fait que
les tricheurs
stade a pu rester ici
[Musique]
bon
ça y est allons-y
qu'elle vous toi je viens c'est moi la
première
moi je préfère chercher dans les laines
je vais le trouver cet anneau je le sens
jandaud tu m'en sers nounours doute aidé
à tout et rira bien qui rira le dernier
oh oh oh oh je me demande rien cet
anneau moi je vois d'ici
là
et le beau collier
des pitas home et pepita sa gueule la
petite sauvageonne elle remporté mon âne
ou aa à aa et votre collier doré aussi
un
gars comme ça bonjour encore jeu là nous
et nous connu je lui en fais cadeau et
la prochaine fois c'est moi qui
gagnerait non mon pauvre tu as ce sera
moi allez discuter de 1 moi je dors d'or
cornichons comme toi demain je vais
m'entraîner avec la note alalalala var
entraînez-vous dada vous en avez besoin
mais moi j'ai de la technique salut
salut gros rancart
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais que fait don ce nounours une
jodoigne heureux vous vers eux allons ne
t'excite pas grand joueur il est l'heure
de laisser des enfants sans dormir
tranquillement ce vrai pas trop en route
bonnut des enfants allez vite vous
couchez les fêtes de bourg
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]